people are going absolutely bonkers over
Hillary Clinton's emails former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton has
come under fire after the New York Times
reported on allegations that she skirted
federal record-keeping laws by using her
personal email account for her work
communications as Secretary of State
currently the law requires that email
correspondences to and from federal
officials be archived in the event that
they should become the subject of an
investigation or congressional inquiry
all right so I'm conflicted about this
story because I get it you can't have a
personal server and when you're working
for the State Department you're supposed
to use their email address and all that
so I get it whatever they did here was
sort of shady on the other hand we live
in this endless outrage machine
constantly and I feel like two days from
now we'll have the next Bill Cosby story
or the next Brian Williams story we're
all gonna forget about this where does
this fall on your outrage ohmmeter very
low I mean personally for me emails like
a source of anxiety it's just other
people's to-do list for me so I feel for
her that like she's trying to separate I
don't or not separate work personal it's
fine I just feel like if this is the
worst thing everyone can come up with
about Hillary pre-campaign or whatever
it is fine let it be I'm looking for
certainly you've had decades to work on
Hillary Clinton and you know Benghazi
didn't stick then it's this email thing
but also I just think that for me I mean
it's a you know this is a sort of a
silly argument her personal emails must
be archived I mean everybody reads every
email anyway we all know that from what
you know snow didn't release them yet
right like they're reading my emails
right now the reading they're watching
the show hopefully and so I just think
this idea that just because they didn't
come through a certain place and they're
not they're not archived is is crazy but
you see that coming from the State
Department where they're now you know
saying that they're trying to find these
emails to so to me like there's
something fishy in there because you
know everything is archived somewhere
whether she's using a gmail account or a
hotmail account or State Department so I
you know I don't know I think it's
there's a story here but whether or not
it's blown up to this proportion right
so it's kind of funny when you factor in
the Snowden stuff in the NSA stuff it's
like even if she was trying to do
something shady they probably couldn't
have gotten away with something shady so
what do you make about the outrage part
of this because that's the one of the
things I really want to focus on as we
do
show is just this three day news cycle
thing they say it's a 24-hour thing but
I find out things actually stick a
little longer it's like a three day
thing where we're outraged everyone's
going crazy and tweeting out and then it
disappears this one's gonna disappear
pretty quick right and isn't even too
early to damage her anyway would if this
was so damaging when they wanted to wait
for another eight months or something
it's certainly not too damaging to I
returned not too early to damage her I
think it could if it was like the Sony
hack and you actually uncovered her
talking some serious [ __ ] about
something right that could happen right
and that may end up happening if she has
to release these emails after this this
conflict but for now it's just the fact
that they're not quite available isn't
isn't enough to but I do think to your
point you know when we're talking about
what's important in the world right now
you know we're spending this time
focusing on it meanwhile you have Isis
smashing museums full of you know
priceless antiquities and you've got the
you know the world warming up on this
coast and then there's blizzards on the
East Coast I mean there's stuff that we
can be talking about as a country that's
probably a little more salient than the
emails that she's sending I I just don't
believe that those emails can disappear
I wish that I could delete emails
personally but I know that they live
somewhere right so so to that point
though with this distraction machine
that's going on we are a news
organization why is it that when people
want to talk about the things like
what's going on with Isis and I saw that
that video where they're destroying this
priceless stuff why don't we focus more
on that and instead we focus on all this
other distraction why is the media
feeding it to us well it's like the the
important versus the interesting right I
think that a lot of things are
interesting to people and that's sort of
what drives the economy of news if
someone finds something interesting the
news reports on it
whereas the interesting stuff is is what
we should be reporting on and making it
interesting enough that people want to
read it and not the other way around
right so it's like this when we report
about this story what we talk about is
how people can get involved there's a
great nonprofit transparency which we'll
put a link to here they work constantly
with helping people have more
transparency in their government so for
us it's an opportunity where people have
the choice you're if you're outraged by
this and you think it's crazy well then
support organizations that are working
to find a solution if you're not then
you
go flip onto the next story yeah that's
right alright so there is a link right
down below that's part of what we're
gonna do here it's not just talk it's
action to what final thought on this
what this is partly making me think is
that like why would anyone want to be a
politician at this point now knowing
that we all grew up in this digital
world anyone that's growing up younger
than us now everything they've ever done
every snapchat and cyberdust that's a
new one and whisper and all them it's
all gonna be there like you gotta be out
of your mind right well that's the thing
too is like you'd think at this point
there have been enough case studies of
people just being brought down by their
by their digital history that we would
be more cognizant of what we're putting
online and I think snapchat was a bit of
a response to that right kids being like
oh we should be worried about what's
going on Twitter [ __ ] you we're just
gonna use snapchat instead and you're
not gonna have access to that which of
course they found out without it we do
but I think that you're gonna see either
much more leniency moving forwards on
whatever your digital footprint was when
you were young and dumb or you're just
gonna see ways around that right digital
products being developed that actually
do keep privacy private yeah privacy
private she's a dreamer conversation is
important though and when people when
you when you you know snapchat comes out
and says that everything disappears and
then it gets released that it doesn't
people should hold them accountable you
know our whisper where it's the same
thing where you say this is a big secret
and then you're selling that information
to somebody else you should hold those
companies accountable especially as if
you're building a whole product on spits
a whole their conversation about right
to privacy right and does that even
exist and can legislation catch up with
technology ever yeah when it comes to
that I think that frankly right to
privacy is a fallacy to a certain extent
and Hillary Clinton of all people should
know that so probably you know if we do
actually uncover something crazy in
those emails like shame on her she knew
yeah yeah but I don't know if we've all
listened do we have privacy I don't know
we're doing this online so we're putting
this stuff out there publicly but we
have private lives - do we have any
right to those private lives what do you
think is this Hillary thing gonna blow
over is this gonna take her down let us
know in the comments right down below